>> Sean: AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY," REPORTING FROM DALLAS
TONIGHT.
COMING UP, FBI BOSS
CHRISTOPHER WRAY GRILLED ON
CAPITAL BILL.
AT SOME OF THE HIGHEST LEVELS,
JUST COMPLAINED THAT
DONALD TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE TERRORISTS OF
AL QAEDA.
SO MUCH FOR THE NEW ERA OF
JOURNALISM.
THIS GUY CHRIS LOOK AT FAKE NEWS
CNN, MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO
GO BACK TO STEPHEN COLBERT WHERE
HE CAME FROM.
LATER TONIGHT, NEW YORK HAS GONE
FROM BAD TO WORSE AS THE CITY
REFUSES TO LOCK UP REPEAT
OFFENDERS, ALL IN THE NAME OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
NOW MANY RESIDENTS ARE FORCED TO
TAKE MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK WHAT LOCAL
BOXING AND MMA COACH LEAPT INTO
ACTION AGAINST A VIOLENT
CRIMINAL, BUT FIRST WE BEGIN
TONIGHT WITH A COMMON THEME FROM
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE AND THAT
IS ONE OF WEAKNESS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I MUST ADMIT, I SPOKE ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF MY BEING ABLE
TO BUY ONE OF THOSE CORVETTES
THAT ARE ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
I'M NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
IT BECAUSE I CAN DRIVE A VEHICLE
WHILE I AM PRESENT BEER >> GOOD
FOR THE ECONOMY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
>> THANK YOU.
IS IT ALL RIGHT IF I ASK A
QUESTION, BRIAN?
>> OF COURSE, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M JUST GOING TO ASK SECRETARY
YELLEN TO OFFER --
>> BEFORE YOU DO, CAN I ASK A
QUESTION?
>> OF COURSE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS
UP, ANYONE CAN SEE THE JOE BIDEN
IS PHYSICALLY, MENTALLY JUST
GONE COME OUT OF IT COMPLETELY.
HIS KNIFE POLICIES ARE EVEN
WORSE
HE THINKS HE CAN SAVE THE WORLD
WITH A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF NEW
TAXES AND FEDERAL SPENDING.
80,000 NEW IRS AGENTS.
WE ARE GOING TO MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF IRS AGENTS AND
THEN OF COURSE EVERYBODY NEEDS
AN ELECTRIC CAR.
HE ALSO BELIEVES WORLD PEACE CAN
BE ACHIEVED THROUGH APPEASEMENT.
SADLY THIS KIND OF WEAKNESS
ALWAYS, ALWAYS INVITES
AGGRESSION.
LAST YEAR BIDEN ATTEMPTED TO
APPEASE THE TALIBAN, GIFTING
THEM TO GRAHAM AIR FORCE BASE TO
ALLOW THEM TO MARCH RIGHT AT THE
CENTER OF KABUL IN RECORD TIME.
IN JUST A FEW MONTHS KABUL IS
ALREADY A SAFE HAVEN FOR
AL QAEDA.
THE TERRORISTS ARE HONORED
GUESTS OF THE TALIBAN AND LET'S
NOT FORGET WHEN BIDEN TRIED TO
APPEASE RUSSIA.
THE SHINY NEW PIPELINE AND PUTIN
IMMEDIATELY, WHAT DOES HE DO IN
RETURN?
HE INVADES UKRAINE AND THE
DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS WITH RUSSIA
ARE SUCH A DISASTER HE HAS
TOTALLY FAILED TO FREE THE WNBA
PLAYER BRITTNEY GRINER WHO IS
NOW ROTTING AWAY IN A RUSSIAN
PRISON CELL BECAUSE OF A WEED
PEN, NINE YEARS IN JAIL AND
CHOSE WORDS TO VLADIMIR PUTIN
ARE COMPLETELY MEANINGLESS.
THIS ALL DESPITE OFFERING UP
MERCHANT OF DEATH.
REMEMBER THIS GUY WE TOLD YOU
ABOUT IN A PRISONER EXCHANGE.
THIS TERRORIST AND INTERNATIONAL
ARMS DEALER WAS CONVICTED IN A
PLOT TO KILL AMERICANS.
AMERICAN'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
RUSSIA IS AT ITS LOWEST POINT
SINCE THE COLD WAR AND WE ARE
SEEING THE EXACT SAME THING
UNFOLD WITH COMMUNIST CHINA.
AND TONIGHT IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
CCP WANTS TO INVADE OUR ALLY
TAIWAN.
CHINA'S MILITARY HAS BEEN
BREACHING TAIWAN'S AIRSPACE.
THEY ARE FIRING MISSILES NOW
OVER TAIWAN AND THE CCP NOW
THREATENED TO ASSASSINATE THE
ALLY AFTER HE WAS THREATENING
JOE BIDEN AND JOE BIDEN NOTHING.
DID BIDEN THREATEN PRESIDENT XI?
HE DID NOT.
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT,
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES,
TREATMENT OF THE MINORITY UIGHUR
COMMUNITY, NO.
JOE GOT LECTURED BY PRESIDENT XI
COME IN ON THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
WREAKING HAVOC ON THE ECONOMY
ALREADY STRUGGLING.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING NOTHING TO
DETER ANY OF CHINA'S AGGRESSION.
INSTEAD HE IS TRYING TO APPEASE
COMMUNIST WITH TARIFF RELIEF.
WHY WOULD YOU BENEFIT CHINA AT
THIS TIME.
EVEN TRIED TO DISTANCE HIMSELF,
DEPLOYING A U.S. MISSILE TEST.
BEYOND PATHETIC, IT WON'T WORK
AND WILL PROBABLY INCUR MORE
AGGRESSION AS WE GO DOWN THE
ROAD.
CHINA IS NOW PREPPING FOR
POSSIBLE INVASION OF TAIWAN
BEFORE THE 2024 ELECTION.
HE WON'T EVEN PICK UP THE PHONE
AND HAVE A TOUGH CONVERSATION
WITH HIS OLD FRIEND,
PRESIDENT XI.
OUR VERY OWN PETER DOOCY ASKED
ABOUT THIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS KNOWN HIM
FOR DECADES.
HE HAS A LOT OF FREE TIME IN THE
RESIDENCE THIS WEEK.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE FREE TIME.
>> HE CAN'T PICK UP THE PHONE
AND CALL?
>> HE'S BEEN WORKING THROUGH HIS
ILLNESS, QUITE FRANKLY, PETER,
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
INSULTING.
>> IT'S NOT INSULTING --
>> IT IS.
>> TO SAY THAT SOMEONE IS
ISOLATING BY HIMSELF.
>> YOU'RE SUGGESTING HE HAS A
LOT OF FREE TIME AS IF HE'S NOT
DOING ANYTHING AND YOU KNOW THAT
IS NOT THE CASE, PETER.
>> Sean: BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH OF ANYTHING ON HIS
SCHEDULE.
WE KNOW HE WAKES UP LATE, GOES
TO BED EARLY SO I